ما التفاصيل التي توفرت حول مقترح لتبادل
اسرى في الايام الاخيره وكيفيه تعامل
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
معه نعم وفقا لما ورد في قناه التلفزه الث
ع هذا المساء فقد افادت القناه بان
نتنياهو تحديدا عمل على اضافه شروط وتجديد
هذه الشروط الا اسرائيليه بل وعرقله منحى
ومقترح كانت قد وضعته في الاونه الاخيره
جهات مختصه وفقا للقناه بالاضافه الى
اطلاع ومشاركه وزراء مجلس الحرب من بينهم
بطبيعه الحال وزير الدفاع يوف جلان
والوزير بيني جانس وكذلك جادي ايزنكوت
ولكن بعد ان تم وضع هذا المقترح دون
الافصاح عن تفاصيله ولكن ما تحدثت به
القناه الثال ع هو ما الذي ستوافق عليه
اسرائيل وما الذي لن توافق عليه اسرائيل
ضمن هذا المقترح لكن بعد ايام قليله اعلن
نتنياهو دون اطلاع الوزراء في مجلس الحرب
على ذلك بانه لن يكون ذلك ممكنا وعمل على
عرقله هذا ال المقترح الذي قدم ربما للمره
الاولى من الجانب الاسرائيلي او كان بصدد
ان يقدم من الجانب الاسرائيلي وذلك في
اعقاب ضغوط كبيره من قبل بعض المسؤولين
السياسيين والامني في اسرائيل وايضا بفعل
الضغط من عائلات الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه
الذين طالبوا في الايام الاخيره الماضيه
ان
تبادر اسرائيل الى وضع مقترح وعدم
الانتظار فقط لمقترحات يتم تقديمها من قبل
الدول الوسطاء ورفضها بالعاده من الجانب
الاسرائيلي في قاب هذا النشر في القناه
الث ع اصدر ديوان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو بيانا قال فيه بان كل ما رفضه
نتنياهو حتى اللحظه هو مطلب حركه حماس
بانهاء الحرب كشرط من شروط اي صفقه تبادل
وهو ما يصر عليه نتنياهو لكن من الواضح
السي ان هذا النشر في قناه التلفزه الث ع
والكثير من المعلوما الاخرى هذه الليله
التي تم الافصاح عنها بشان خلافات في
المواقف سواء كان على
مستوى الخلافات مع القياده العسكريه
والامنيه والخلافات مع جلنت واقصاء جلنت
من اجتماعات وقرارات امنيه هامه اتخذها
نتنياهو في الايام الاخيره الماضيه وهذا
الاعلان ايضا بخصوص
الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه وصفقه التبادل
انما يؤكد عمق الخلافات بل وتوسع رقعه هذه
الخلافات على مستويات مختلفه بين نتنياهو
وبين الاجهزه الامنيه من جهه التي يمثلها
ايه يواف جلند وهذا يعني ان هناك فوضه
كبيره جدا في مواصله هذه الحرب في اتخاذ
قرارات حاسمه تتعلق بهذه الحرب في رؤى
مختلفه ما بين المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه
وما بين نتنياهو واقطاب توليفته الحكوميه
من الاحزاب اليمينيه المتطرفه هذا اليوم
حتى راينا هجوما مباشرا من بن كبر الذي
طيله الوقت يحاول نتنياهو ارضاء هذا
التيار في حكومته تيار بن كبر وسموت من
الاحزاب الدينيه المتطرفه هذا اليوم نقل
في موقع واللا بان بين كفير وجه رساله
شديده اللهجه لنتنياهو يتحدث فيها عن
انتقادات بخصوص قرارات يتخذها مجلس الحرب
دون دون الرجوع الى المجلس الوزاري المصغر
الذي يعتبر بن كفير عضو فيه وتحديدا فيما
يتعلق بسحب قوات من غزه هذا اليوم تم
الاعلان عن ان حزب العمل ينضم الى حزب
يوجد مستقبل
برئاسه يائير لابيد وا قرروا تقديم مقترح
لحجب الثقه عن الحكومه هذا اجراء بالعاده
روتيني في ايام عاديه ان تقوم احزاب
المعارضه طيله الوقت بتقديم مقترح لحجب
الثقه عن الحكومه في داخل الكنيست لكن ليس
في وقت الحرب السي وكل ما يحدث عمليا
حاليا بدا يعتبر ال فيه العديد الكثير من
الفوضى والكثير من حاله عدم الثقه اخذه
بالتعمق واخذه بالتوسع هذه الاختلافات على
مستويات عده في مجلس الحرب وفي المجلس
الوزاري المصغر وبين القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه في اسرائيل